trabajar en españa' podría ser algo más
fácil para miles de extranjeros gracias
a una reforma del reglamento de la ley
de extranjería aprobada hoy por el
gobierno de pedro sánchez la medida
beneficiará tanto a quienes están en el
país de manera regular como a los
indocumentados entre otros los
estudiantes podrán compaginar trabajo y
estudios siempre y cuando estén
relacionados y no superen las 30 horas
semanales algo que antes estaba
prohibido también se elimina para éstos
el requisito de haber vivido durante
tres años en españa' para lograr un
permiso de trabajo post estudios por
otro lado los que han estado en el país
al menos dos años de manera irregular
podrán pedir la regularización por
arraigo con tal de que se formen en
sectores con falta de mano de obra como
por ejemplo la construcción o el
transporte y consigan una oferta laboral
según el ministerio de inclusión
seguridad social y migraciones es una
reforma necesaria debido al
envejecimiento de la población española
que además evitará una economía
sumergida incentivada por las trabas
burocráticas que alargan los procesos de
contratación en el país la decisión del
gobierno entrará en vigor en tres
semanas sin necesidad
aprobada en el parlamento y podría
cambiarle la vida a un estimado de medio
millón de trabajadores indocumentados en
españa' que suponen un 10% del número de
extranjeros en el país alguna
organización de emigración es tildan la
reforma de insuficiente y creen que
convierte a los migrantes en pura
mercancía laboral